c'est au niveau de ses stations d'eau
d'ici de revirements à quelques mètres
du quartier rabin vilaine trois victimes
maïs charlon âgé de 22 ans avait rendez
vous avec ses amis le 28 décembre
dernier point de simple partie de
dominos panciera maïs et sollicite un
voisin de son quartier de doute aux
environs de 21h arrivés sur place
certains mais le conducteur du véhicule
assiste à une scène inimaginable quand
celle des jets de monter l'otan est en
tout cas d'après me l'a commencée dieu à
sa mesure
cazouls d'hérault tout de suite de son
intervention il a fait le tour de
voiture et
le gala du compte
paradis commando armé des désastres y
mettre l'imagination des aventures ça va
tout de suite on avance était carrément
claire ly qui ça continue malgré le vote
négatif maïs passionné de football a
fait ses premières armes au club
colonial
il devait cette saison signé une licence
halo giroud doute surpris et attristé le
président du colonial se souvient de ce
gamin qui brandissaient fièrement sa
première coupe en catégorie u19
j'étais un gars avec ses bons mots
sympathiques que nous n'avions pas
identifier comme source de soucis liés
pour lui-même n'y avait pas des
comportements addictifs dangereux pour
lui-même au bout d'autres c'est triste
pour lui c'est triste pour te cache une
espagne et qu'est ce qu'ils trouvent
souvent confrontés à ce genre de choses
aujourd'hui c'est une mère de six
enfants
ravagé par la douleur qui témoignent les
médecins ont diagnostiqué une
tétraplégie c'est un jeune en bien quoi
il a pratiqué du sport il a il a eu des
diplômes et là il a fait l'essai m'a
donc à la cua
l'avocate de la famille m boulogne en
thing les plombs tout de même la durée
de la cavale du tireur un homme
dangereux selon m
nous avons été alertés que sept
agresseurs se trouverait à l'hôpital ce
qui fait que nous avons été obligés
d'indiquer aux forces de l'ordre qu'il
fallait se rendre à l'hôpital ce qu'ils
ont fait et effectivement ils n'ont pas
trouvé
donc nous sommes effectivement heureux
de savoir qu enfin cet agresseur a pu
être appréhendé mais la famille est loin
d'être soulagés est loin de connaître le
répit
quand vous avez un jeune de 22 ans qui
est être appelée gic
l'instruction de ce dossier est en cours
inévitablement le présumé auteur de sept
tentatives d'homicides sont à confronter
aux nombreux témoins de la scène
ce suspect âgé de 26 ans sans profession
déclaré
originaire de lamentin risque 30 ans de
réclusion criminelle